you don't always know when it will be
the last time to make it short yeah I'm
retiring from competition
you don't always get to choose when an
era is over and it's all on the coach
one verse is true to try and keep his
team alive keep the dream alive for them
well they're right up behind him the
flick not connecting and he is brought
down we knew for sure that as the last
CS go major Paris would be the end of
something but it's still managed to
surprise us present and correct and if
they were in the feed to start jail
hey the chosen one is here the Paris
major showed us exactly how far a
Counter-Strike has come
knock he's only got one two OC nervous
nervous no way
[Applause]
and he's getting edged up he needs some
backup and he will not be there in time
siphon with the jewel he's now one
versus two trying to hunt them down oh
they're staying here he should be dead
when he hits the headshot coming back
he's looking for it and there's no way
and just like the game itself it wasn't
what we expected but it was even better
than we thought look around you we own
this Arena CS go came to France for its
final farewell say [__] them as old
foreign
Counter-Strike Global Offensive was a
bridge that brought two communities
together source and 1.6 France mostly
known for their Source skills stood out
early on pacing himself he's gonna spot
nbk first he goes down a ldlc they pick
it up and look at that they can hardly
believe it but the country's triumphant
run didn't last and even though France
won two CS go Majors its competitive
scene was racked by controversy cheating
match fixing and personal conflicts kept
French players away from another major
title after their 2015 Victory and
nearly compromised even that win France
waited on the sidelines as Brazil and
then Denmark dominated different eras of
the game it felt to many like French CS
was doomed to never win again the blast
TV Paris major was announced in
September of 2022. it was going to be
the first ever CS go major hosted in
France but the last of the entire game
this was a big deal not just a French CS
fans but to France as a whole president
Macon while seeking re-election in 2022
promised to bring a CS go major to his
home country and Mac Hall announced the
major two a few months after winning
that re-election the blast TV major
combusters
foreign
the stage was set for a French CS
Revival but whatever we expected once it
actually got started the Paris major
continued to surprise
the major didn't exactly start with a
bang but by the legend stage things
really went off the rails some of the
strongest teams in the world measured
themselves against newcomers and came up
short a lot of utility in the mix okay
Cipher in the feed a quick headshot
between the eyes too to start off
proceedings he is the brunt and The
Brute
of this attack it's all Cipher take them
all starting with a bang starting as he
means to go on he is within touching
distance of making history for the UK
they already have him go he wants the
ace
call him baby and that's gotta feel good
so much damage crucial should be a dead
man smoking come down
crucial
magnificent in the finish it was a
bloodbath as anyone who did Pickens can
attest hop out Alexi goes beyond him
knock shoots him in the back as Alexi
just writes off the possibility and Knox
gonna get ever closer catching bows it's
gonna be tough with the awp rez already
starting to clear out some of these
angles in the bomb site Brolin's walking
knock hits the shot Rez is gonna stick
this or not gets him off and now time is
gonna decide there is no chance for the
ninjas teams that everyone expected to
win teams who were looking to cement
their legacies by taking home the last
ever CS go major went down in disgrace
instead we've got Crimson sight Dodges
The Flash he's looking for his moment
and fire at the feet of the Moto play
now faster still with nothing and the a
side itself is holding oh crims he's
losing his teammates but fights the King
of Kings inside will take that 15 for
fnatic but has that been a problem they
can fixate forward oh and a first one on
Nico straight through the smoke a dive
under the bomb but he doesn't stop
playing even doubt and hooks he wastes
no time Nika does right there backs turn
hits the shot a second and Nick adoles
is now one away as the kid Prodigy whose
dreams will be crushed alongside the
Kovach and all the sudden he peeks he
goes down g2's failure to qualify for
playoffs was a huge disappointment for a
roster that had never managed to clinch
a major despite adding young hot shot
monessy to bolster the presence of one
of the game's greatest ever riflers I
was close many chances has slipped away
uh
new chapter starting in CS2 and that's
it Navi with the goat himself simple at
the helm we're looking for a second
major and an emphatic statement that
this was their era but their chances
Slipped Away First losing to Monty a
team that had beef with simple listen I
like the balls of this kit to come out
publicly on Twitter and call out symbol
who is the greatest player of all time
in Counter-Strike Global Offensive and
say something like you're watching right
now in this quotation is is speaks
confidence you know speaks belief in his
own abilities that Molly implies as such
especially with bit Juan But Here Comes
krasnell he's still on the site has his
foreign
just like that Warroad takes a step in
that direction one back but that's all
it's all wore out one more on that
Warpath 16 secure Monty up in the lead
in this Grudge Match for a spot in the
champion stage and then at the final
hurdle they were stopped by
International Powerhouse Face Clan this
could actually still grow bad for Navi
there's a good pick off green 20 seconds
he picks up the one ready as they come
through and oh my God Reign with the
last spray down taking bit a triple on
the Norwegian and it's all on The Gulch
one versus two to try and keep his team
alive keep the dream alive for them oh
they're right up behind him the flick
not connecting and he is brought down
Brookie to send Navi out of the major of
the top eight teams that made it to the
playoff bracket a staggering five of
them qualified from the Challenger stage
and among the Titans left standing were
Vitality the sole French organization in
the tournament and the one hope for the
home proud but they stood almost
entirely alone most of the other massive
CS go names had fallen before even
reaching the final leg of the race and
in their place were teams that few
expected to make it this far Monty into
the breach Apex
gamer Legion not exactly the biggest
names in the game but look more closely
and you'll see something bubbling
beneath the surface these seams
represented years of changes that CS go
brought to the scene and the potential
Counter-Strike 2 could bring on Monty
ukrainians some Die Young and war02k got
their revenge on the greatest player
ever and their Kinsmen and prove that
they could be the next generation of Cs
Talent it's only simple
he's still thinking about the 18th of
September
there's Monty securing top eight one
frag away can for us ended here yes he
can that is beautiful for Apex it was a
Resurgence of oldenings and a younger
players hungry to find Glory that
knocked out North America's Only Hope
sneako still sneaking
one
I am in disbelief
[Applause]
first stage
no problems but gamer Legion best
embodied the chaotic bloodbath of the
Paris major and they reveled in it they
were an international team cobbled
together from across Europe and had made
it this far through sheer persistence
despite an atrocious 0-2 start in
Challengers how do you do this though
when he's solo on hellframe one little
mistake not that he's even making one
right now he has no idea where to look
oh awkward scenario a little sprayed
still unlikely he can win the round but
he knows where both of them are at the
very least
Crim's just hiding back there recording
a bit good headshot hold the phone there
should have been no way he should have
been dead inside of the smoke to begin
with looking right over the spray is
good
coming up with a mass one versus two
clutch gamer Legion were led by shuhi a
20 year old polish igl who was attending
his second major shuhi came up through a
talent development pipeline that simply
didn't exist when some of his opponents
got their start in the early days of
csgo he played his first games at 15 and
after being scouted by polish Esports
organization izako bores he spent over a
year on the Mohs NXT developmental
roster while living and studying in
Northern Ireland an opportunity like
this for a young player to affiliate
with an established Esports organization
and play tier 2 Counter-Strike in a
stable environment wasn't always a
possibility the opportunity arise to
play Miles NXT and the only option for
me to join that team was basically to
become an igl there was no other role
for me there was no other option and
because I already showed some attributes
or characteristics of an igl before in
my first team I decided to give it a try
I I don't think I was doing too bad at
it I was also getting praised in music
from my for my teammates and and my
coach so I decided to give it a try and
I think it clicked instantly the very
first day whenever I had it CS Go's
explosive popularity made Counter-Strike
into a real industry and if that hadn't
happened the path that shoe he took to
the top would have been impossible for
an aspiring CS Pro instead the 20 year
old stepped onto the playoff stage in
Paris having already igl'd for almost
two years he'd been signed with Esports
organizations for over three years and
had already attended the Rio major where
two of gamer legion's three Challenger
stage losses were to eventual top 8
teams so maybe we didn't all expect shui
and gamer Legion to show up like this at
the major but thanks to those who came
before them they definitely had the
tools to do it shoe hey
nurtured in the academy League he was
destined to be next he got a taste for
what's the championship mentality
requires and it was instilled in him and
once the playoffs began game religion
showed Paris exactly the kind of threat
they represented and the chemistry
behind it and here he is now
kios fan favorite he who was chatted for
on his approach
vitality's homeboy
frag grenade goes out not destined to
find either two oh
the queen now
interesting position Emma
he steps up and says Monty step down
bomb down again forces sdy to double
back and they're gonna jump on this in
an instant but kiosk oh there's an
answer written off each and every time
the curse of Rio that loomed over them
Shuhei watched all his old teammates do
what he wanted and now he has done it
himself
he leads by example here on overpass
with every member of the Legion taking
it A step above defeating Monty another
Dark Horse in this unpredictable race
even with their victory over Navi was
one thing but taking on heroic led by
legendary Danish igl Canadian was
another thing entirely the bomb is still
in the hands of sui oh they're gonna run
right and join him with the spray down
he moves them all right down USB and
boiler the only Presence at this bomb
site in okay well doesn't even get
really a chance Eva Antoine is going to
spray them all down quad kills
and it's 12 to 11. it's going to draw
him back that's a huge red flag they
know what's coming soon on the kill as
well and now yabby and Katie are showing
up Emma with the spray down he's so good
is Immortal it's just Tess is left and
there's nothing to do very Legion with a
Legendary Run to make the grand finals
of the final nation in CS go gamer
Legion were in a major final they were
winning hearts and Minds even in hostile
territory how nice is it to have these
guys completely on your side I honestly
just [__] love it
but the home crowd was still hoping that
their own team would join them there
since the end of the online era team
Vitality struggled to find consistent
footing we couldn't we couldn't beat
them today it's [__] happens but we have
three more tournaments at the end of the
yearbook
then we get one I swear we'll get one if
you keep playing like this and you keep
holding out we get one of these tonight
and throughout it all there is the
underlying question what exactly needed
to change for the French organization to
find
consistency for some the answer was
getting rid of Apex now a 30 year old
French rifler who took over as the
in-game leader in March of 2020. he had
won the last major for France at
collusionapoca in 2015. it was the only
player to win an International
Tournament in every year of Cs go
competition but at times Vitality seems
to fold when it should have been able to
hold including at the pgl Stockholm
major and more often than not Apex was
blamed for his team's failures there had
been flashes of Brilliance from the
lineup of course with a roster of this
talented the ceiling was never in
question but even the addition of sphinx
a Hotshot Israeli rifler who had proven
himself with a breakout performance on
ends failed to really kick-start the
roster's results at the subsequent Rio
major or the blast World final later in
2022. still if you can't find true
consistency then the next best thing is
to get hot at the right
time and vitality did just that plenty
of players to defend against this and
they want to be aggressive they don't
want to give any room over not a lot of
utility for Vitality to manage it and
give themselves some room to work with
that's a good find they need the head
shots to create the space but they swing
out a little bit too wide double kill
for Rollins all the trades are there and
through with the rebuttal into the
breach of they're not good enough but
Roland is responding one quick kill
retake still gonna be tough and it's
Magis to deliver a couple a new one 1v1
ridiculous you hunted him down with a
head shot now Cipher is looking for him
but that bomb is down there taking away
sign for yeah
[Applause]
busted out of it the Sting from Meg is
too much for into the breach to handle a
quad kill to begin with and vitality a
kill away from the semi-final crucial
he's being hosted
and mortality they've made history
tonight
[Applause]
in the semi-finals for the first time
what feels like a date with Destiny
favorites to win the trophy and they
will not be stopped here by into the
breach a strong Victory Vitality went
undefeated in the legend stage turning
French fans into Believers for the first
time in years but again the lineup of
teams waiting for them in the bracket
wasn't exactly what they expected in a
way not having to play teams like Faze
or heroic was a blessing on the other
hand Vitality had the pressure of being
heavily favored in front of their home
crowd and the other teams put a Target
on their back but make no mistake
Vitality had experienced despair before
joining the French team magisk had won
three Majors with legendary Danish
lineup astralis and Dupree had four
young French Superstars xiwu was still
looking for his first but his
performance Against The Underdogs didn't
betray any Nerfs either Apex forward
Newark on that off has to be a
contributing member here is Apex goodbye
and space
for Vitality here
it may not be of concerned
touches propels three three
that is Pedigree and look at that for
the Finish
brought down 15 is all the damage dealt
Steve goes deep no way no not now how is
he still alive he's down to two HP he
somehow lives on and now they're pushing
again
unlike so many of the other big names
Vitality were able to cut through their
side of the bracket and meet gamer
Legion in the final it's been so much I
don't know how to describe it but the
feeling I have is the best in my life
and for an end to Counter-Strike Global
Offensive the symbolism on display was
absolutely perfect vitality's roster was
composed of two Danish Legends a rising
Israeli star and two Frenchmen one a
long time veteran of the game the other
a young Superstar hungry for his first
taste of major Glory standing on home
soil across from them were game religion
a pan-european mix team with an average
age of 22 nearly four years younger than
vitalities the roster had greatly
benefited from the infrastructure built
during the game's period of dominance
and looked remarkably calm as they faced
the arena what's more the two igls could
hardly have been more different a 30
year old veteran who was proving he
still had it versus a young star whose
path existed only because players like
Apex had shown us all what
Counter-Strike could be and who had
everything to prove old versus new
experience versus potential the old game
versus the new one one team that
represented everything Counter-Strike
was and one that represented everything
it could be the home crowd was firmly
behind the French side and vitality got
off to a hot start the only way we lose
this is we lose ourselves and that's not
gonna happen then one player issue he
could outperform Apex and that could be
a game on our hands starting to press in
timing looking like it is perfection
double spray down from debris every time
gamer Legion step on the ball to repel
they fall Spinx steps behind pillar
repeats with Apex alongside him can
vitality
and now Apex is left to clutch they're
close so close Point Blank blank he
shoots it's so damn close
this is all he needs
there's a bit of space offered up from
both sides but now time decides we're
beyond that halfway point smoke goes tap
on bomb shoe hay Nails the first kill
zaiwu Taps it yet again but it is too
late to close
one more kill and vitality find
themselves map up in a major Grand Final
there it is
[Applause]
their first showing
of golden moment after losing their own
map pick of overpass game religion
seemed like they'd be doomed on
vitality's pick nuke but they were
determined to make it count on the top
of this ramp has gone unchecked a
beautiful Moment by seven snaps two
kills from the corner and a third with
just the sidearm there he is aim high be
high says never ever shoot the low the
neck bout time on top of that dual
Vitality give them that bit of space
nice run boots off no a car broken
Beamers Capri and Zaid will pop back up
good amount of money for capris
in with one in a clean conversion for
Vitality I was got him now he's making a
ton of sound the bush with the ball back
oh it's the multi
cyber's got that fresh mag ready for
some more ready for a third serving
how many courses to this meal as zaiwu
pops right back up
oh the ramifications of losing the
losing this one
would be one thing if you're able to
just look at a single pinpoint moment
where where something could have gone
your way it was close
but it wasn't enough
[Applause]
surrender
France had earned their third CS go
major on home soil at the absolute last
possible moment Apex won his second
after more than seven years Sphinx
became Israel's first major Champion
zaiwu didn't miss his last chance in CS
go and his earth-shattering performance
earned him an MVP to boot and for the
two Vitality players from Denmark they
each made history with majisk earning
his fourth major and Dupree forever
immortalized as the only player with
five and Apex well after all of the
doubt and pressure here at the game's
end he proved the haters wrong how does
it feel
I don't know what to describe right now
it's so much joy you know I've been
criticized from day one being in game
leader but no I win the [__] major so
[__] you
and the assembled French crowd did the
thing that they had waited so long to do
they're Champions standing before them
they sang France's national anthem La
marseillaise around the world more than
a few fans sang along with them France's
impact could have faded away after its
early glory in CS go instead a new
roster and a new Superstar Opera lit the
torch for a new generation at the
perfect moment and for gamer Legion who
followed their 20 year old igl all the
way to the end it was a setback sure but
it was also a reminder of why we all
love this game I remember I was watching
virtus Pro play and I watched like them
stand on the stage and all these fans
and just having the support they had
back then and then suddenly 10 years
forward it's apparently Mis is standing
on the stage and I remember even after
we lost the Grand Final I was standing
on the side of the stage and I was
looking over all these people just
basically they are the ones making my
dream come true even though they're
cheering for the other team I was just
thinking what would we actually do
without these people coming here today
and even those guys at home watching
those are exactly the people that made
my childhood dream come true and many
hundreds of other people the Paris major
gave us the poetic send-off that CS go
deserved even if it didn't shake out the
way we expected it showed us that in the
modern game you have to be on every time
if you want to succeed because the
competition is better than it's ever
been and if the next game's last major
is even half as good as this one it will
mean the Counter-Strike isn't just alive
it isn't just thriving it's
forever
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
[Music]